Aesthetic evolution,
animals are agents in their own
evolution.
That is it through their choices,
they ended up shaping their own species.
One of the implications of this idea is
a new perspective on what happens when
mate choice is infringed or violated by
sexual violence or by a coercion in,
uh,
in animal species.
Uh,
one prominent example of this from our
own research is on duck sex.
A ducks are,
uh,
unusual among birds in having both a,
a,
a typical mate choice situation where
male and females pair up on the basis of
display and preferences and
simultaneously other individuals that
forced copulations on,
on a female docs as the approach
reproduction.
So what that means is that,
uh,
as the eggs were being laid,
females have to defend themselves from a
forced copulations by males.
Now,
forced population is the word that
biologists use now,
but force over a century.
A biologist used the word rape in
biology.
Now that was abandoned back in the 19
seventies in response to the feminist
movement.
And Susan Brown Miller and her work a
against our will,
uh,
proposing and articulating a
specifically a social context for a rape
in humans.
This led to the creation of a euphemism
forced copulation in biology.
Unfortunately,
articulating a sexual violence in the
animal world with these euphemistic
terms has led to scientists losing track
of the fact that forced copulation is
against the will of the ducks.
And by taking the aesthetic perspective
and trying to understand what it is that
individual females in this case,
stocks want.
A,
we have arrived at a,
a new perspective on what it means when
they don't get what they want,
right?
So in some ways,
uh,
using,
socially sensitive euphemisms has led to
a,
a precision or fuzziness in,
in the science.
In the case of ducks x.
What we find is that males can force
themselves on females because they are
among the few birds that still have a
penis.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what we find in docs is the,
as a result of a female resistance and
male sexual violence,
we find a,
a,
a coevolution,
a arms race between male,
a capacity to force and female
resistance.
In this case,
it takes place in the form of a genital
arms race.
The males evolve,
a more elaborate and more elaborately
armed penises.
And the females evolve convoluted
vaginal morphologies that exclude the
penis during forced copulations.
So the,
uh,
among the many weird things that a duck
penis is,
is that they're counterclockwise,
coiled,
uh,
well,
the female,
a vagina in ducks that have a high rates
of resistance actually coils in the
opposite direction.
So they have literally evolved in it
screwed device,
uh,
in their vaginal track that,
that ubs a,
obstructs the intermission of the penis
during forced copulation.
Um,
what that means is that the,
uh,
what that tea party,
Senator Kennedy,
Todd Akin from Missouri said,
uh,
about,
women have a way of shutting that whole
thing down in reference to,
to rape is actually true of ducks.
But in a way that exposes something
fundamentally new and interesting about
evolutionary biology,
which is that sexual autonomy matters to
animals.
Freedom of choice is not merely a
political concept in discovered by a
suffragettes and feminists in the 19th
and 20th centuries,
but it's actually an evolved feature of
the social and sexual lives of other
species,
especially in docs.
How does this work?
Well,
if the female mates with the male she
prefers,
that is she gets the green had in the
quack,
quack that she likes,
and then her male offspring will share
that those traits and be sexually
preferred by other female docs who have
coevolved those same aesthetic
preferences.
But if she's forcibly fertilized,
then her male offspring will either
inherit a random trade or one that she
specifically rejected,
which means that her offspring will be
less attractive to other females.
So anything that female duck can do to
prevent force fertilization through
physical resistance or behavior will
evolve because she will be rewarded with
more grandkids.
Right?
So what this means is that a aesthetic
norms,
these shared ideas about what is
beautiful among ducks gives female ducks
the evolutionary leverage to advance
their freedom of choice in the
environment of persistent,
a sexual coercion and sexual violence,
right?
Uh,
this is really stunning.
In fact,
we know these ducks are so successful
because in species were 40 or 50 percent
of the populations are forced,
only two to five percent of the eggs in
the nest are fathered by males who are
not the social partner.
What that means is that females have a
98 percent a successful,
uh,
birth control device.
That is a behavior of Lee,
a deployable in the vaginal tract in
response to sexual violence,
right?
That's like FDA approvable,
And what that shows is the power of
female choice to advance,
uh,
the sexual autonomy of individual
females.
One of the interesting things we learned
from,
uh,
examining,
um,
uh,
sexual conflict in docs is that,
the genital arms race between males and
females is not really a fair fight.
In fact,
uh,
the advances in feet in male coercive
capacity are really about control over a
female outcomes,
right?
They are about controlling,
physically controlling a fertilization.
However,
the countermeasures that females evolve
are not actually about power or control.
They merely reestablish a,
uh,
the,
the freedom of choice,
if you will,
the flat playing field in which
individuals are free to choose who they
like right now,
this,
this sexual autonomy is not actually
about a control or control over other
people's,
uh,
or over other individuals,
sexual outcomes.
That's fascinating because this is a
cemetery between,
uh,
a male,
male coercion and female resistance in
duck sex,
uh,
has really fascinating parallels to a,
um,
a patriarchy and feminism in cultures
today.
So,
for example,
a patriarchy is historically and even in
a modern sense about coercive control,
uh,
over female reproductive autonomy,
whereas feminism is a really an ideology
of freedom of choice,
right?
And that's so that same cemetery between
male power and,
uh,
and freedom of choice a is elaborate and
present today.
And we can see this explicitly because
patriarchy and a men's rights,
uh,
and in cell a movements all articulate
feminism as a countervailing force have
control over a male reproductive
outcomes.
Uh,
but that's a fantasy.
In fact,
uh,
the,
the sexual autonomy includes the freedom
to be rejected at which,
uh,
is,
a lesson that we learned from duck sex.